i already know what you're saying
but paul his dog materials isn't out yet
and in some respects you'd be right i've
kind of gone back and forth over what to
do with this as the show is releasing
one week later in the us but as this is
a uk-based channel i thought i'd drop
the break down in line with that
and anyone who wants to wait a week is
more than welcome to add this to their
watch later list and check it out down
the line
that being said there's a lot to unpack
from the entry
and as always if this is your first time
checking us out then welcome to the
heavy spoilers show
and hopefully you enjoy our week by week
coverage on the series
there will be some minor spoilers here
in regards to the book
so if you don't want anything
potentially ruined for you then i
recommend that you turn off now
as for the entry itself we pick up right
after the events of season 1
which saw lyra stepping through the
terror in the fabric of her reality
this is mirrored by will who did the
same thing on his end and both me up in
the entry
whilst it feels like a lot of fun and
games throughout
this episode very much sets up the great
war that is coming
on one side are the magisterium who wish
to find the subtle knife through will
and on the other are the witches who
believe that lyra will be the key to
their salvation
in the wake of lord azrael opening up
the portal to another reality
the world has stumbled into chaos the
witches believe that this is the
fulfillment of a prophecy laid out long
ago
that states all existence will either be
destroyed
or made anew juxtaposing this the high
ranking members of the magisterium
believe that lord azrael burnt the new
world into existence
and that to state it was already there
is heresy at one point they capture a
witch and torture her
which forces the group to launch an
attack on them which we'll get into in
just a bit
now this episode is very much about both
will and lyra meeting
and forming a union with one another
early on
lyra arrives at the town of sitagaze
which is the same location that could be
glimpsed through the northern lights in
season one
citagasse which i'm definitely
pronouncing wrong i'll try it with a bit
more italian
that's terrible now that that roughly
translates to city of magpies
which just so happens to be the name of
this entry
sorry if you've just unsubscribed as
well now in case you don't know
in the books the seaside location is
based on an italian
mediterranean town and throughout its
cobbled roads and ancient architecture
we can see abandoned homes in
restaurants at the center of it lies the
torre de gallo angeli
which translates to the tower of angels
and within it is held the subtle knife
which of course ties in with will's fate
now with this new world comes new rules
and similar to lyra's dimension this is
tied in with puberty
in lyra's world mrs colter wanted to
separate children from their demons
before they hit puberty
in order to save them from sin she
believes that if she accomplishes this
on a grand scale
that the entire world will be free of
sin and nurse has been carrying out
experiments on children
for what she views as the greater good i
know it goes beyond that but
it is an important rule to pay attention
to as this idea of adolescence causing
problems
is very much tied in with this new world
the sita gaze
is pretty much devoid of adults and by a
zombie-like one named tulio that we
encounter in the entry
the entire location is really just
populated by a gang of children
who is that leona leona's back
anyway we discovered that the city is
actually haunted by invisible ghosts
known as specters once a child starts to
mature
these spirits become visible and they
suck the souls of their victims
leaving them in an almost undead-like
state now the reason that the specters
are emerging around the city
is because of the subtle knife which
exists in the tower
the knife is actually capable of opening
up the window between worlds
that lyra used to travel to this one
however this
comes with a caveat and the more the
knife is used the more the specters are
created
when azrael opened the passage at the
end of season one
it actually caused a massive rise in
specters
and these swarmed the city this is why
lyanna who
i know she's not called up but i should
she was good wasn't she anyway
this is why she mentions an attack on
the city which was of course
kick-started by asriel's
short-sightedness most of the adults
were either consumed or they fled
and thus the children have remained in
the citade setting up a sort of lord of
the flies aesthetic
now alongside this idea of worlds being
mirrored and having rules that in some
way reflect one another
we also get this idea of how words
differ slightly depending on which world
you're on
demon and dust of course means something
completely different in ours
and i loved how there was this idea
throughout that depending on
which world we visit will depend on how
certain rules and standards are
interpreted
i think the city gaze is an incredible
location
and the spiraling staircases eerily
empty streets
and towering monuments really add a
certain mystique to the entry
hearing the wind blow through the
location and realizing
how empty it is adds a lot of nuances to
it
and i think this easily becomes the most
interesting locale that we've visited so
far
along with the creepiness we also have
some cute moments
such as lyra making omelettes for will
and being
unable to do so because she's been
brought up being weighted on hand in
foot
these light-hearted moments really add a
touch of character development to the
episode
and they're juxtaposed brilliantly by
the storyline involving the witches and
mrs coulter
it begins with the former inviting lee
scorsby to their cliff top meeting
and here they sort of set up the mission
that he will be going on
which is to get an object of protection
from a man named gruman
this is actually another name for john
parry so their paths will be crossing at
some point in the season
the witch meeting is sort of an
exposition dump and it's mainly used as
a setup for the group protecting lyra as
she continues on the main quest
now whilst it does sound a bit fillery
i'd sort of compare it to aragorn side
quest in lord of the rings
which had him basically protecting frodo
and sam
whilst they went on the main mission
there are definitely a lot of potential
avenues that they can take things and
i'm excited to see what happens
especially with the witches and
magisterium going head-to-head
now as mentioned on board the submarine
culture
slowly tries to suck the information out
that she needs
from a witch that they've captured
colter tortures her prisoner by ripping
the magical cloud pine out of her back
and as we learn this is tied to a
witch's ability to use magic
as we've discovered throughout the
series colter has no problem with
separating people from their magical
abilities and demons
and thus this torture scene mirrors what
she's planning to do to children across
the planet
the witch almost gives up who lyra is
but instead calls for death
and this comes in the form of the newly
introduced witch queen ruta
ruta flies in like a bow of hell and she
instantly proves to be a force of
reckoning for the magisterium
not only does she kill the prisoner and
release her from her torment
but she also moves faster than the flash
and takes out the forces of the evil
group
she leaves the cardinal in critical
condition and culture strikes up a deal
with
father mcphail who that that's that
sounds like your dad's nickname
anyway she she makes a deal with him in
order to snuff out the cardinal
and supplant him coulter is extremely
seductive
and we've pretty much watched throughout
the entry how she has used her sexuality
to control the men
and lead them into achieving her goals
she's clearly after controlling the
organization and i loved watching as she
slowly put things in place to put
herself in a position of power
elsewhere lyra and will strike up a deal
to travel to each other's oxfords
and find things to continue their quest
this is quite a big chapter in the
source material
so i can see it being a huge part of the
next episode as we get into them
journeying from one world to the next
the pair agree to travel in the morning
but will wanders out into the street
which is where a is surrounds him and
thus the episode ends
now i don't think it's a big spoiler to
say that the character isn't
dead but how he will get out of it is
gonna be really interesting to see
we also have the fact that lyra now
knows he's a murderer
and though the compass says to trust him
she's of course
questioning its reliability due to what
happened with roger
i think we're really gonna see in the
next episode as the pair walk a day in
the opposite shoes
and come to learn all of the things that
caused them to be in this current
position
as for the episode itself i did really
enjoy it
and though it was a lot of setup i think
the intrigue of the specters
and the city itself really gave this
entry a life of its own
anyway that wraps up the episode and i'd
of course
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you leave them in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of the mandalorian
which is going to be linked at the end
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of november
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat just
under discord server linked in the
description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
you